printers row book fair up next robert
dalek on nixon and kissinger his latest
book on their difficult partnership in
running american foreign policy
good afternoon welcome to the 23rd
annual chicago tribune's printer robe
book fair
we're pleased to provide a forum where
book lovers and authors can come
together and exchange thoughts and ideas
we would like to give a special thanks
to the heartland literary society the
co-sponsor of this program just a few
housekeeping notes before we begin
today's program
this is being broadcast live for book tv
on cspan2 and out of courtesy for our
panelists and guests if everyone could
please turn off your cell phone and all
other electronic devices
that would be great thank you and also
flash photography will not be permitted
and now i'll turn it over to our
moderator jim warren managing editor
of the features for chicago tribune
thanks jim
well hello everyone and thanks for
coming indoors on this gorgeous day
outdoors after a kind of cruddy spring
for the tribune book fair and thanks
also to my friend
brian lamb the notoriously
hot-tempered opinionated celebrity
pandering founder of c-span
who has put aside c-span's usual
afternoon coverage of professional
lacrosse and women's beach volleyball
to allow me to talk to a renowned
historian bob dalek
i'm actually somewhat cowed
atypically by bob's presence and this
opportunity to discuss his absolutely
super new book nixon and kissinger
which reminds us that one can really
meld a meticulous scholarship with
engaging writing to turn complex history
into page turning veritable beach
reading assuming one is not playing
beach volleyball
i thought i actually thought i knew
these two guys very very well
until i read this book which is rich
with new material and insights
a friend of mine and a dalek admirer of
brian williams the nbc anchor suggested
to me the other day that those who love
history are living in a golden era when
it comes to sophisticated popular
accessible history lucky to have the
likes of bob and david mccullough and
doris kearns goodwin and michael
beschloss and douglas brinkley among
others in our midst and in a business
this history writing stuff that's if
truth be told is not short on sniping
and behind the back you know football
fights
i've encountered no real critics and
certainly no enemies of bob only
admirers
that said we must now note that bob
apparently made some publishing history
this week if a discreet advertisement in
last monday's new york times was correct
if it was correct bob actually had a
book reading and signing at a new york
city office furniture store the other
night
indeed at a place called dalek office
furniture 269 madison avenue founded in
1920 it turns out by his paternal uncle
now come to think of it showing up at
book fairs is so predictable in pro form
isn't it
same with those earnest appearances at
the local borders or barnes and noble or
those interviews on npr's fresh air or
even five minutes of usually failed
premeditated author humor when surfacing
as a guest
on the john stewart show
bob now has come up upon something i
think path breaking for an industry
whose marketing skills make those of the
newspaper industry
resemble ringling brothers and donald
trump combined
imagine this sort of sales pitch in the
future
buy two han file cabinets and get a free
copy of nixon and kissinger
or buy three steel case beige cubicles
and get copies of both nixon and
kissinger and the equally wonderful
unfinished light bob's book about
president john kennedy finally maybe we
can envision a holiday weekend
blockbuster sale memorial day july 4th
you buy 10 herman miller black air on
chairs and we'll give you five copies of
each book and lunch with the author
well we didn't have to buy even a single
fluorescent bulb today so let's knock on
wood and welcome bob to the book fair
[Applause]
okay first question bob why in 2007
should we care about the relationship
between nixon and kissinger what
relevance does it really have for our
understanding of the american presidency
or the conduct of world affairs well
before i answer that jim i should tell
you my favorite anecdote about these
wonderful introductions that i get like
the one you just gave
always puts me in mind of an
introduction i got when i was lecturing
the soviet union many years ago
my host on that occasion who i like to
think had an imperfect command of
english
introduced me by saying professor dalek
is the author of several distinguished
works they're the kinds of books that
once you put them down you can't pick
them up again
i didn't trust that guy
why why why nixon and kistje 2007
well
they're i think uh terribly relevant to
uh
current events
here were two uh
very important uh makers of foreign
policy
they were
probably two of the brightest guys to
make foreign policy in in american
history
uh with deeply flawed characters and
they were
fierce rivals
what i found so striking when i started
to work on this book
was the thought that
this is going to be a hard book to write
because nixon was so secretive and this
was probably the most secretive
administration in the country's history
to that point
and um uh
i just said will i be able to penetrate
the veneer
and the irony the irony
was that this turned out to be the most
transparent administration
i've ever studied and i've studied quite
a few
because as jim knows there are 2 800
hours of nixon
telephone con or tr
tape conversations
20 000 pages of henry kissinger's
telephone transcripts
uh eight hundred thousand pages of
national security files
uh including al haig's what's called
kron files
uh the hr bob haldeman diaries uh which
were published but by no means in as
full of form as you can find them on a
cd-rom in the
archives where they're kept
and so
what i was able to do was get
beyond
the public image
all these folks
want you to think that they walk on
water
and that they collaborate and that they
are sort of idealistic fellows that they
operate in thoughtful considered ways
they have no doubts about what they're
doing and of course what you see
is two men
who struggled
with the decisions they had to make and
sometimes they made awful decisions it
seems to me sometimes they made very
wise decisions but what's also so
striking
is the extent to which they battled with
each other
they were driven they were two men who
were so eager for power
so eager to
shape the world
shape american history
and
they were jealous of each other they
collaborated i would describe it as a
kind of unhappy marriage
and
it i think echoes with so much that has
gone on
in that post-nixon presidential era and
so much that goes on today now you know
we can go and get into all sorts of
specifics
iraq vietnam
chile
american secret
machinations abroad
so i think there's so much to be learned
in fact i say at the end of the book
that
this book should be taken as a
cautionary tale
and that
we should learn something from it
though i sometimes as a historian
despair and i remember what the german
philosopher hegel said which is that the
only thing we ever learned from history
is that we never learn
and i'm afraid there's more truth to
that than i'd like to believe
since you referred to it as a marriage
why don't we next go to something that
fascinated me what one might then term
the courtship
of these two men
1968 nixon is running for president
against hubert humphrey lyndon johnson
remember has opted out could you tell
people what you learned about
kissinger's relationship
to both campaigns the humphrey campaign
and the kissinger campaign and how would
you characterize
nixon's knowledge of kissinger
when he appointed him
to
his initial top post
well
they didn't know each other
in 1968 they met once very briefly at
some cocktail party in manhattan
but in 68
kissinger who was very eager to have a
position in administration a
high-ranking position influencing the
making of national security and foreign
policy
he played both sides of the streets
he was in the humphrey campaign
and would occasionally go to paris to
get information about the
ongoing vietnam peace negotiations that
johnson had
set in place
and he would then
report back to the nixon folks about
what was going on in paris
and so
the understanding i think on his part
was that if humphrey won the election
he'd get a position in the humphrey
administration if nixon won
there might be something for him there
his greatest hope was that if nixon won
he was going to make nelson rockefeller
secretary of defense and in fact he
encouraged nelson rockefeller to become
secretary of defense and then kissinger
could become one of his principal
deputies at the defense department he
didn't know that he would become a
national security advisor now
why did nixon appoint him
it's an interesting question
nixon wanted to run foreign policy he
makes a man named bill rogers former
associate in a law firm in new york his
secretary of state rogers didn't know a
hell of a lot about foreign policy and
that's exactly what nixon wanted he
wanted to control foreign affairs he
wasn't interested in domestic affairs he
said domestic affairs was a matter of
building out houses in peoria
he wants to make his administration a
foreign policy presidency
he wants kissinger there because he'll
be a kind of adornment here he is
distinguished harvard professor who is
the author of
books and articles about national
security about nuclear weapons and he
thinks he can very much control him you
see
he should have known about the anecdote
that some of kissinger's colleagues told
about him at harvard
which goes as follows
kissinger was teaching a seminar
and
it was a warm summer's day and he came
out on the harvard campus and saw an
assistant of his
sitting with
a young english woman who was an
aspiring journalist who was in the
seminar
he went up to them he started chatting
with them and this young woman was very
cool to him and annoyed him and so he
blurted out to her why don't you like me
and she said because you're a fascist
he said he said fascist why i was in the
invasion of belgium she said really with
which army
so
what nixon quickly learned was that
kissinger was a rival for power for
influence and in fact there's an early
conversation
nixon began taping in 1971 february 71
there's a conversation between him and
bob haldeman
in which
they say if
henry manages to drive bill rogers out
he will become a dictator he'll try and
control all of foreign policy so very
early on
nixon is very tense about this
relationship with kissinger now there's
lots more to say and i'll you know get
back to it but
he thought about firing kissinger a
number of times
but he couldn't do it because once the
opening to china took place
and kissinger became a public figure a
kind of celebrity and then this 72
campaign came along
and
he couldn't get rid of him in 72 and
then watergate and especially once
watergate
took over the nixon administration
kissinger became all the more important
and powerful influential and nixon
became
all the more
resentful and to conclude this little
description
uh brent scalcroft who i interviewed for
the book told me that nixon would
complain to him repeatedly about
kissinger and how much power he was
accumulating and there's a famous
conversation between
nixon and gerald ford the night before
nixon resigns
and he says to him jerry he says
you got to keep henry in place
he's essential vital to the national
security to the making of foreign policy
but every once in a while
you got to kick him in the nuts because
otherwise he's going to run away with
power
to be graphic
no expletives deleted
bob what was most
surprising to you as your research
unfolded i mean as you mentioned yes
there's vast quantity of information on
what on one hand was perhaps the most
secretive white house ever
but now because of all this information
all these tapes is arguably the most
transparent
white house uh ever what surprised you
might it be for example
one area i found very compelling and you
might want to just give folks some
background on it 1973
yom kippur war and what you learn about
the white house decision-making process
which included dealing with somebody who
was
drinking heavily
at the time
um i mean if that's one of the things
the yom kippur war tell folks a little
bit about that and what we now know
about the kissinger and nixon roles at
this critical moment
absolutely jim
nixon is by the yom kippur war october
73 he's
deep in the throes of this watergate
crisis
terribly worried that
he may be impeached that'll be forced
out of office
and
when the war begins i think it's october
5th or 6th kissinger gets a call at six
o'clock in the morning
he does not speak to nixon
until three three and a half hours later
and when he speaks to nixon nixon
practically begs him
to be telling the press
that
he's been
briefing the president every hour about
developments in the middle east
because nixon is so worried that the
press is going to see him as irrelevant
as no longer someone who is competent
and
in control of uh the presidency
a week later there's another
conversation
in the uh transcripts
in which uh uh
brent scholcroft calls up kissinger
and says to him it's five day in the
evening he says henry
the british prime minister edward heath
has called and he wants to speak to the
president half an hour
and kennedy says brent we can't do it
the president is loaded
and they agree that the president will
speak to the prime minister in the
warning but in the meantime kissinger
will
speak to the prime minister
two weeks later
the egyptian third army is surrounded in
the sinai desert by the israelis
and the soviets are very apprehensive
that the israelis are going to force
that army to surrender
they want to
uh
rescue it or at least preserve it from a
surrender
and they call up kissinger and
propose that they're going to send a
paratroop brigade into the middle east
into the sinai and they want the united
states to join with them
a joint military effort to save this
egyptian third army
hague and who is now al hague is now uh
uh uh
nixon's chief of staff
at the white house because uh
holdem has been forced out in april of
73 over watergate
hayden kissinger 10 10 in the evening
they have a conversation
and hague says uh
you can have a meeting about this
soviet problem because she says yes
where are you going to meet at the state
department hake says no no you must meet
at the president's house at the white
house
in other words in case word gets out
there's a meeting he wants it
the impression to be that
the president is running this show he's
in charge see
because he said it's fine
he then says to hey where's the
president
and he says he's asleep
because he says should we wake him up
hank says no
half an hour later they talk again and
egg says well did you talk to the
president
because he says no i don't want him
charging around here
seven unelected officials including led
by hague and kissinger then hold a
meeting
and they agreed to raise the def com the
defense condition the nuclear alert
only twice in the cold war did this ever
happen the first time during the cuban
missile crisis under kennedy and the
second time during this yom kippur war
i asked the archives i asked john powers
the archivist
is there a single document demonstrating
that kessinger had rather nixon had any
input in this
discussion these deliberations
there's nothing there
they claim
that they uh consulted nixon
i don't believe it for a minute
they went ahead and made this decision
to raise the defcom without nixon's
direct input i'm sure they were
confident that they were reflecting his
wishes and they probably were
but they did it without him being
present or having a direct input the
next day
after the soviets have backed down in
the face of this threat
kessinger the first one he talks to
after hearing this is not nixon he talks
to hague
and hague says to have talked to the
president yet he says no i'll be calling
him shortly see
and uh
they then say
well we don't want the press to think we
quote unquote cook this up
which is of course what they did
so i found it
shocking
that they should go ahead and do this
kissinger then calls nixon and he says
to mr president you've won again
and nixon in essence
is grateful what is he going to do
say to kissinger at this point i'm
firing you see he's grateful
but
there's a kind of uh
i raise in the book the question of
whether
kissinger is secretary of state now
should have raised the question of the
25th amendment of the constitution
should they have invoked this amendment
to try and suspend nixon's power because
he's incapacitated it seems to me or at
least somewhat incapacitated well what
kessinger understood was that it
probably would have been impossible
because nixon was not so incapacitated
that he could not have been said
impermissible this is a kind of
political coup
and of course kissinger was very
protective of his power he wasn't going
to do this and then have nixon fire him
you see and so he doesn't do it but he
speaks continually about the fact or his
concern
that
nixon's
loss of of judgment that his
incapacity is uh is injurious to
a dangerous to
the national security well if you really
believe that
why don't you do something about it
um bob an audience
my apology there was slight interruption
a few minutes ago that was my three and
a half year old and explicitly less
interested in these proceedings than
um i'm shocked
[Laughter]
in looking at what many have come to
call nixon's successes notably
opening to china dayton salt arms
agreement the soviet union
union a big agreement on berlin finally
ending our involvement in vietnam
what was your conclusion as to
are these achievements a result of
nixon's vision kissinger's vision
combination of the two none of the above
yeah
i think it was a combination of the two
i think they both were very intelligent
men with
a vision as to what they want to do in
foreign affairs they very much wanted to
put into place
what they
call the structure of peace
and that i think the initiative on china
very much came from nixon kissinger was
nixon's instrument in putting that
together achieving that uh dayton with
the soviet union they understood that
nuclear weapons were not usable weapons
the doctrine of mad mutually assured
destruction that you had to arrive at
some kind of accommodation with the
soviet union that these were
great achievements
on vietnam however if i may you know
pontificate on that point a little bit
i think that was a disaster
initially
in uh 69 nixon and kiss you have a
conversation nixon says
there's a tendency in saigon to think
that we can fight this to a victory it's
impossible see he sees this war
as a failed effort
and yet
they go on for four more years
20 roughly 23 000 more american troops
die
tens of thousands of vietnamese
cambodians laotians perish
why do they continue if they know this
is a failed effort
well
they have some hope they have some hope
that the vietnamese
can stand up
while we stand down
sound familiar
iraqization vietnamization see
they know
very quickly that this is a failure in
1971 they encouraged the south
vietnamese to strike at the north
vietnamese in laos where they're
building up their strength
the south vietnamese take a pounding
they get their heads handed to them and
nixon is furious and one of these
conversations he is cursing he is
enraged and he says god damn it if only
they would take a hill capture a few
prisoners they won't use their air force
to bomb north vietnamese trucks because
they are quote unquote moving targets
and he explodes with
anger over that and he says
we have to present this as a success we
can't acknowledge or we can't say it's a
failure you see
their hope is that they can use enough
military power to intimidate the north
vietnamese into making what nixon
describes as peace with honor
and so the cambodian incursion
so this laotian effort by the south
vietnamese so the christmas bombing of
december 1972 which does force the north
vietnamese to the peace table and into
an agreement
but
they don't have confidence at the last
nixon is told by kissinger when he gives
a speech on this
on this peace agreement
he says kissing just says nixon don't
describe it as lasting
not don't call it lasting he doesn't
believe it'll last and in fact kissinger
has conversations with the soviet
ambassador brennan and with the chinese
premier john lie in which in essence he
asks for
tell the north vietnamese to give us a
decent interval doesn't use that term
but that's what he's talking about a
decent interval because they have no
confidence that this will
south vietnam will be
all that sustainable
so the final question is
why do they do this
they are concerned genuinely concerned
that america's credibility will be
injured undermined with adversaries and
uh
allies if if
we walk away from vietnam and it's seen
as a failure as a defeat
my argument is
that
the fig leaf they put on the end of the
war in 73 could have been put on it in
69 early 1970 you see
in fact american credibility would have
been enhanced rather than undermined if
they got out in 69 or 70 because the
attitude around the world
to coin a phrase was that we were
throwing good money after bad
that america would then have its
resources to use in much more
constructive productive ways
but as a final point
in december 1970 kissinger has a
conversation with
bob haldeman that he recorded his diary
holdman says to kester henry the
president wants to get out of vietnam by
the end of 71 and kissinger says bob
it's not a good idea if south vietnam is
unstable in 72 it could jeopardize
the president's re-election
the political cynicism you see
now nixon does get out of vietnam slowly
but surely he starts with 545 000 troops
and by the time the 72 election rolls
around there are about 39 000 troops
left
but
the deviousness
the manipulation
the deceptiveness with which they
operated
and nixon kissinger of course wins the
nobel peace prize for the for the ending
of that war he never should have wanted
for that
somebody some journalist called it the
nobel war prize see
he should have won it however
for the shuttle diplomacy
that opened the door i believe to the
camp david peace accords under jimmy
carter
so uh
there are these
i don't know quite what to call them but
perversions of history if you will and
uh but that these were the most
thoughtling things i saw since you dwell
so much in vietnam i do have a question
and want to tie into current events but
uh here's what we're going to do i'm
going to ask bob two
quick questions and insist on concise
responses and then the folks who want to
go to that microphone right in the
middle uh it'll be your turn for about
six or seven minutes so i'm just going
to ask my two final
questions to what extent
have you come to see any similarities
between nixon and kissinger's policies
and actions in the vietnam war and the
bush administration's policies actions
uh vis-a-vis the iraq war
oh i see striking similarities in fact i
published a piece in the washington post
outlook about three weeks ago today
which was titled iraq is not like
vietnam except when it is
and it is
this business of iraqization and
vietnamization this idea
that we are training them and they'll be
effective
i'm no military expert but
you know as they used to say in the 60s
you don't need to be a weatherman to
know which way the wind is blowing
and you just see
it seems to be such a fruitless effort
and
people are dying
young men young women
for what
to what end to what purpose
we're going to save and preserve our
credibility our credibility is
undermined every day i think we stay
there and sacrifice so much blood and
treasure
i
think there are such striking
similarities and misjudgments
that have been made here
as they were made with vietnam
there's such a striking parallel and i
must say to my satisfaction and maybe
it's my grandiosity that leads me to
this conclusion
but about three days after that
op-ed article of mine appeared
bush gave a talk at the
coast guard academy in which he said
that
tried to refute the idea that
iraq is like vietnam
but a final point i'd make jim is that
why has there been
this rising crescendo of dissent about
iraq so quickly after all in vietnam we
lose 58 700 american lives i don't make
life for a second of the 3 500 american
lives that have been lost there already
but why there's no draft why is the
descent
so strong already because
this war stands in the shadow of vietnam
and people remember what happened to us
there and i think they wisely understand
we're repeating the mistake we made
earlier
my final question is coming and please
feel free to go to the microphones i'm
going to turn it to you guys bob real
quickly particularly given what
your research
brought your way and the insights you
gained
how does one explain when it comes to
henry kissinger
the maintenance of this
worldwide reputation fame and cachet and
this this air of credibility
it's it's a
question that is maybe impossible to
answer
i asked him when i interviewed him i
asked him what do you think accounts for
your celebrity after all secretaries of
state come and go nobody remembers
cordell hull anymore the longest-serving
secretary of state in american history
and fdr
and his response to me was
what do you think accounts for my
celebrity
he didn't like my answer but
i think i think
well i told him that i had a
conversation with bob schieffer not long
ago who said to me he thought that henry
was extraordinarily adept at
convincing the press of his
effectiveness of manipulating them so to
speak and he said that wasn't the only
thing i said of course not
i have been studying these politicians
all these years for nothing uh
he um
his his celebrity i think in significant
part rests on the fact that during that
kiss nixon administration there was such
a collapse of authority that he was the
one who in the sense shouldered it and
uh gave the sense that he was the shield
the country's shield against the dangers
in the cold war at the time and in a
sense he's uh sustained that but
you would think that his standing would
be eroded by the fact that now he's
known as someone who's been advising
bush
and again to what good end but uh uh he
just does have a kind of hold on the
public imagine the public's imagination
that is really extraordinary it's gonna
be interesting for years from now for
historians biographers to continue to
study this and try and understand
this man's impact and influence
we're going to start with questions
we'll try to get to as many as possible
if we miss some it's going to be because
of a time limit that's imposed on us
please just identify yourself questions
short and sweet sir please go ahead
this is from one of those outhouses in
peoria this question uh you made or the
reference was made to the richness of
the material that you had
for researching to do this book my
question is do you think historians 30
years from now will have this same
richness of material to talk about this
presidency or have post
nixon presidents got better at
controlling the material that will be
available today that's a fascinating
question as a professional historian i
uh i've wrestled with this already my
brief answer is of course i don't know
they don't make tapes anymore they
sort of learn from the nixon watergate
experience not to tape
i'm hoping i'm hoping that emails will
become the tapes of the future but of
course we have to capture those we have
to because people are so indiscreet when
they
do these
emails
on the other hand the hope i have is
that these folks are also grandiose and
so eager to leave their mark on history
that it's amazing to me what they leave
behind
what they are willing to
leave for
historians to
listen to in the future
read study so i don't know the answer
and
we probably won't know about this
administration for the next 30 years
because that's how long it takes for
these uh papers materials to come to
hand sir
paul warhol chicago professor to what
extent if any
did
dr kissinger have with uh
richard nixon's enemies list
did to to what extent did kissinger have
an enemies list as well to what extent
did richard i mean to uh did dr
kissinger participate if at all
in the nixon enemies list he he really
didn't
i mean in any full direct way but he did
have his own enemies and he did uh
sort of stroke nixon
and i think you know helped to inflame
his paranoia because for example during
watergate there's one conversation in
which he says to nixon
these
democratic
bastard senators are traitors
they're trying to you know drive you out
deprive you of
the power that you've essentially
genuinely uh gained so he would stroke
nixon he'd tell him things like mr
president without you this country would
be dead
uh
he was masterful at pressing nixon's
buttons he understood what a terribly
insecure man this was and he understood
how to how to manipulate him in a sense
hi russ zigler i'd like to get your
ideas on what you think of the public at
least congress's right to know what was
going on during the next administration
when he was incapacitated especially
when you had people who were conspiring
not to get that out as well as people
who didn't know which orders to follow
and which orders not to follow that you
want to know what congress what what
your thoughts are about the public's
right to know as well as congress's
right to know
during this time when he was so
incapacitated as you talk talk about
well
that's the the essence of our democracy
you see here
i am an admirer of what the press does
because without a an aggressive press to
try and open
windows to let the sunlight in
we will be we would be so much worse off
this is not to say
that they do everything perfectly
at times i think they're
too cautious
it's a very difficult business though if
you're a white house correspondent and
you want to have access
do you go out and denounce them every
other day i was watching helen thomas on
last night being interviewed by tim
russett and where she said she was
persona non grata with this white house
because she's been very blunt with them
and so
they have to be somewhat careful but
that's it seems to me the roots in a way
of our democracy because these folks
will not let you get at the truth and
often the congress is very much too
supine and especially if it's the
congress from the same party it's so
salutary for our democracy it seems to
me to have different parties in control
of different branches if you have
uniform control by one
ideology or one outlook or one party i
think it's it's much less satisfactory
in terms of what we know and what we
understand and
how we should respond to what these guys
are doing
sir paul johnson wicker park and i was
just going to say uh jim we missed you
on the mclaughlin group on friday so
whatever you have to do to talk to the
jesuit to get on there more whatever
well you know given the choice between
spending afternoons that way or spending
with the three and a half year old when
he's in a better frame of mind it's not
much of a choice but anyway okay um uh
doctor i was gonna ask you how how would
you reconcile or how does how would
kissinger reconcile
and i'm not a hobby historian but you
know the whole like jewishness
of you know where you know nixon will
use these words and i've listened to
tapes and i'm sure many here have
listened to these audio transcripts and
how do you i mean how would you
reconcile it how do you think it's well
nixon was very abusive to kissinger in
this regard
behind his back he called my jew boy and
occasionally even to his face
or he would say something ugly about
jews and then he would say to
kissinger isn't that right henry isn't
that right and kissinger would say well
mr president there are jews and there
are jews
or
they would talk about the middle east
and
kissinger would give his opinion then
nixon would say all right now can we
have an american point of view
so
kissinger would retaliate behind the
scenes by calling him the meatball mind
our drunken friend
the maniac
during watergate he said to al haig he
said listen the president has to go out
there and give a speech which makes him
appear to be the father of our country
rather than some raving maniac
and so he could be as scathing so these
are the tensions the resentments that
were just below the surface you see but
the questions have always been asked of
kissinger why didn't you
respond to him and when you would sit
there and listen to him saying ugly
things and his response is that it
wouldn't have done any good his mind was
made up about the press about jews about
certain elements in the society and uh
uh he just you wouldn't convince him
anything and so kissinger's uh dodge on
this is that uh this was the way to
preserve his influence by just being
passive about listening to this
just time for a couple more we are
running down sir michael santo um i can
understand the potential benefits of
getting out of iraq and not being stuck
there but
isn't there a big danger in comparing
our current enemies in iraq and even
potentially iran to much more formidable
enemy north vietnam backed by the
soviets in a cold war context when our
technological edge was much less
significant
well you know
vietnam we had all this anxiety that if
north vietnam takes over the south that
there's going to be a domino effect and
other countries will collapse in
southeast asia it'll be such a blow to
the united states in the cold war
well what happens we win the cold war
did it matter all that much that south
vietnam becomes a
expansion extension of north vietnam now
people people argue that if we get out
of iraq what's going to happen there al
qaeda is going to have a big presence
well hello where were they was al qaeda
there before we went in and obviously
now they have a presence but my
conviction is
that like saddam hussein who would not
allow
osama bin laden or the al qaeda to have
a presence
you're going to get a shiite
dictatorship
and
they will not allow al qaeda to have a
presence a state within a state will
iran have this huge amount of influence
which is another assertion about our
departure from iraq i doubt it
they hate each other there's been a war
in which a million people were killed
some shiites yes would welcome them in
but there's no uniform outlook on this
among the shiites so i'm not so sure
this scenario that this administration
describes is the one that
we can anticipate
we are running out of time but i i have
to allow the gender monopoly here to be
broken so
my name is michelle parisi and let me
preface my question by saying that um
i'm a vietnam veteran i spent three
years in from 66 to 69 in in vietnam
with the seventh fleet
and
we worked out a subic bay in the
philippines um
the
from what you've been able to uncover
did nixon over time come to the
conclusion that the vietnam war was a
loser and we should send kissinger to
negotiate a way out in paris or did he
come to that over time or did he believe
that from the beginning
he believed that almost from the start
and that his understanding was that the
united states had to get out of vietnam
for at least two reasons one was because
we were using resources there that we
needed to have available and that if we
were ever going to get this structure of
peace which they wanted to put into
place they first had to
get rid of this vietnam war and then get
on to better relations with the chinese
with the soviets so from the start they
think this is a a essentially uh not a
cause that they should invest any much
any any more in in any significant way
and yet they stay on for political
reasons for reasons of credibility that
there's a conversation kissinger has
with de gaulle
in
february 69 in which kissinger talks
about american credibility in relation
to vietnam and de gaulle says to him
i would have thought it's your enemies
who have the credibility problem see the
gaul understood that this was a failed
effort and finally there was a
conversation that kissinger has with
stewart alsup the journalist in which
alsup says
this is nixon has to be the wizard of oz
this is going to be one of the greatest
retreats in history and he has to sort
of make it appear
other than that and kessinger says yes
the gall in algeria brilliantly done you
see this is what we have to do make it
appear as if it's a victory we're still
a great power and yet we walk away from
it because it is it is a defeat so the
cynicism the deception which they
practice and a final point i'd make to
you is this people say why did this
nixon administration fail well the
answer on the surface is watergate and i
would say to you that watergate was the
symptom
the cause was the atmosphere of
deception of manipulation of deceit with
the public between the two men you see
does it matter you said you wanted to
ask me that
final question does it matter of course
it matters not only is it ruinous to
presidents because once you lose your
credibility with the public you cannot
govern anymore remember that lyndon
johnson problem the credibility gap how
do you know what lyndon's telling the
truth when he pulls his earlobe rubs his
chin he's telling the truth when he
begins to move his lips you know he's
lying
it was ruinous to him ruinous and the
day nixon said to the country at a press
conference i am not a crook was the day
his presidency was over
so when they're found out it's ruinous
to them but it's also so hurtful to the
country because there's such cynicism
about our institutions people are
rushing now eager for the next election
why they want to get past this
administration they want something new
and that's why i favor obama
[Applause]
before
before we before we say farewell i'm
going to give you literally 20 seconds
you two big new books about mr obama's
uh prime one of his prime rivals hillary
rodham clinton uh you've reviewed one i
think you've read them both you've got
20 seconds should we run out and buy
them what are they what do they tell us
about hillary rodham clinton
hell no jim they should buy my book
um uh
they're interesting books but
in many ways they rehash
one of hillary's
spokespeople said
it's cash for rehash and i think there's
a lot of truth to that on the other hand
they are very interesting and revealing
but to give hillary her do could any of
the other candidates stand up to the
kind of scrutiny she's been subjected to
it's a bad idea to be a front-runner in
one of these campaigns you want to sort
of hang back and then you know like the
uh the great finisher
in a horse race you come on uh at the
end but
what the hell do i know so before you
before you get those go out and buy
nixon and kissinger partners in power we
want to give a million thanks to bob
dalek first and second to all you guys
for coming in indoors on such a gorgeous
day outdoors thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for attending today's
discussion and for supporting the
chicago tribune's commitment to literacy
feel free to stay here for our next
guest or enjoy our programming at some
of the other venues robert dalek will be
signing books in the park room which is
the first room on your left as you exit
and if you would like to purchase a copy
of the book they are available through
barnes noble here on the second floor
thank you
robert dalek on his book nixon and
kissinger from the chicago tribune
printers row book fair
two more hours of coverage from the book
fair today up next a discussion with jan
crawford greenberg writer of supreme
conflict and jeffrey stone
who wrote war and liberty in the final
of the author of the day will be ken
alder talk about his book the lie
detector